YEARS JUST AS HE SUPPORTED
BILL CLINTON AND TED KENNEDY AND
HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
THEY'VE GOTTEN A PASS FOR ALL OF
THAT.
THIS TIME IT'S WORTH GETTING TO
THE BOTTOM OF THEIR COMPLICITY
IF ANY OF THIS.
TAMMY BRUCE IS A RADIO SHOW HOST
IN NEW YORK CITY.
SHE JOINS US NOW.
HOW LONG BEFORE ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN'S ALLEGED ABUSES
BECOME THE ABUSE OF ALL MEN?
THIS IS REALLY A MACRO PROBLEM.
SHOULDN'T WE PAUSE BEFORE WE
SHIFT RESPONSIBILITY TO EVERYONE
AND ASKED WHO KNOW ABOUT THIS
SPECIFIC EYE?
>> YES.
I MEAN, LOOK, THIS IS STILL
SINKING IN IT SO HORRIFIC.
IT'S ONE THING TO BE ARGUING
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
TREATING WOMEN BADLY OR
UNEQUALLY IN THE ONE PLACE, BAD
ENOUGH.
THESE ARE STORIES OF PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE, OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
WHICH HAS NOT BEEN DEALT WITH A
GREAT DEAL WHEN IT COMES TO THE
#MeToo MOVEMENT AND A MAN WHO
WAS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
STATE AND IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
DYNAMIC AND WE KNOW THAT THESE
ISSUES TRANSCEND POLITICS AND
HERE IS THAT THESE ARE MEN,
WHETHER WITH HARVEY WEINSTEIN OR
BILL CLINTON OR THE KENNEDYS ARE
NOW THIS MAN WHO WRAPPED
THEMSELVES IN THE CLOAK OF THE
#MeToo MOVEMENT, OF FEMINISM
WHO SAID THAT THEY WERE THE
CHAMPIONS FOR WOMEN AND ENDED UP
BEING THE MAN THOUGHT THEY WERE
WARNING EVERYONE ABOUT AND THE
PROBLEM IS AS YOU MENTIONED IN
THE RONAN STORY IS THAT FOR
WOMEN ON THE LEFT, LIBERAL WOMEN
HAVE BEEN TOLD AND EFFECTIVELY
CONDITIONED THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
EFFECTIVELY GIVE UP YOURSELF A
WAY IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THE MOVEMENT OR HELP THE LIBERAL
NARRATIVE THAT IRONICALLY THESE
WOMEN WERE TOLD BY THEIR FRIENDS
OR EVEN DECIDED THEMSELVES IN
ONE CASE THAT THEY WOULD PUT UP
WITH THIS BECAUSE HE WAS TOO
IMPORTANT, THAT THE ARGUMENT
THAT WE WANT TO FIGHT TO PROTECT
WOMEN, THAT WE ARE GOING TO
PROTECT A MAN WHO IS VIOLENT
TOWARDS THEM.
THERE'S GOT TO BE -- THIS IS ONE
THING TO EXPOSE THEM, BUT
LIBERAL WOMEN HAVE TO ASK
THEMSELVES WHAT OTHER LIES HAVE
WE BEEN TOLD?
WHAT OTHER THINGS HAVE WE BEEN
TOLD, HOW TO BEHAVE, OR WHAT WE
SHOULD SACRIFICE OURSELVES FOR
AND HERE'S THE OTHER REVELATION
HERE.
SCHNEIDERMAN EXPECTED IN SOME
WAYS, WE BELIEVE, TO BE PART OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S
ADMINISTRATION.
WEINSTEIN AND SOME REPORTS WAS
HER BEST FRIEND AND VERY CLOSE
TO HER.
THE THING THAT HAS MADE ALL OF
THIS POSSIBLE TO COME OUT
BESIDES RONAN PHARAOH'S GREAT
REPORTING AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS
AS WELL LIKE JANE MEYER IN THIS
REPORT IS THE FACT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON LOST.
IF SHE HAD WON ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE BEEN STILL
PROTECTED AND THEY WOULD HAVE
STILL BEEN VICTIMIZING WOMEN IN
MANY INDUSTRIES, BUT CERTAINLY
THIS UPPER CRUST OF THE LIBERAL
FRAMEWORK WITH MEN AND WOMEN
THAT HAVE PROTECTED THEM WHO
HAVE CONTINUED TO VICTIMIZE
WOMEN AND NOW ARE AT A POINT
WHERE REALLY, I CONTEND, IN THIS
FRAMEWORK, THIS LARGEST OMELETTE
IS THAT IT'S ABOUT THE LIBERAL
IDEOLOGY THAT THE RIGHT HAS BEEN
SO DEMONIZED THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
PROTECT EVERYONE IN YOUR REALM
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT AND
CONSERVATIVES WHO ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE THE DEADLY ONES.
AND IT'S HER OWN VICTIMIZERS
THERE ON THE LEFT.
>> Tucker: NO ENEMIES ON THE
LEFT.
I'VE SEEN THIS ALL MY LIFE.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT TO SAY
THAT THERE ARE CREEPY PEOPLE ON
BOTH SIDES, THAT'S FOR SURE.
BUT THERE'S ONE STRAIN OF THIS
BEHAVIOR THAT REALLY IS
PARTICULAR TO THE LEFT AND THAT
IS THE OVERWEENING HYPOCRISY.
WE ARE ALL HYPOCRITES, I GET IT,
BUT THE IDEA THAT THE GUY
TELLING YOU YOU CAN'T HAVE A
WOODSTOVE BECAUSE OF CARBON
EMISSIONS ARE FLYING IN A
PRIVATE CHAT OR THE PERSON WHO
SAYS YOU CAN OF GUNS AN ARMED
BODYGUARD FOR THE #MeToo
ACTIVIST BEATING UP WOMEN.
NORMAL PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE THAT
HYPOCRITICAL -- NORMAL PEOPLE
COULDN'T DO THAT.
I WILL PICK ANOTHER ISSUE.
I KNOW I'M BEATING UP WOMEN SO
I'M NOT GOING TO BE LIKE THE
#MeToo SPOKESMAN BUT LIBERALS
DO THAT AGAIN AND AGAIN, WHY?
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?
>> I WOULD CONTEND THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IN THE ISSUES.
ANYMORE THAN BARACK OBAMA CARED
FOR HEALTH CARE OR GETTING RID
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR ISIS.
THESE ARE MECHANISMS FOR THEIR
OWN POWER.
THEY USE THEM AND ON THE LEFT
YOU GET PROTECTED BECAUSE YOU'VE
ALREADY CONVINCED EVERYONE ELSE
THAT YOU WERE NOT THE ENEMY.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S HYPOCRISY
BECAUSE TO BE A HYPOCRITE I
SUPPOSE YOU HAVE TO KIND OF SORT
OF BELIEVE IN THE ISSUE AND THEN
DO THE OPPOSITE.
THEY DON'T REALLY BELIEVE IN IT
AND THIS IS OUR PROBLEM, THAT'S
THE LIBERAL PROBLEM NOW IS THAT
HAS THIS JUST BEEN A GAME?
DOES NO ONE BELIEVE IN THE
ISSUES AND FOR THE WOMEN THAT
HAVE BELIEVED IN IT, LET THIS AT
LEAST HOPEFULLY MAYBE BE A
CRACK -- YOU WANT A BROKEN GLASS
CEILING?
IT IS ONLY HAPPENING BECAUSE
HILLARY CLINTON LOST AND NOW
THERE'S A CHANCE FOR LIBERALS TO
BE HONEST AND MAYBE IT'S THE
KANYE WEST THEORY.
MAYBE THEY CAN HAVE FOR YOUR
MINDS WHICH WILL LEAD TO SAFER
LIVES AND GENUINE INDEPENDENCE,
WHICH IS WHAT LIBERALS AND
CONSERVATIVES, ALL AMERICANS
GENERALLY WANT TOGETHER.
WE CAN STOP ALIENATING OURSELVES
FROM EACH OTHER AND COME
TOGETHER FOR THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE IN COMMON.